how do you like your salmon cooked
poached pump fried baked parchment pack
so i took the same slice of salmon and i
cooked it four different ways what are
the differences in how you cook them
compare and contrast texture and flavor
and ease of cooking
[Music]
this one definitely tastes healthy i
think it's very clean flavor it doesn't
have additional fat i feel like with the
poached one you could taste more of the
flavors in the water honestly the
blandest
of the four i think you can easily fix
it seasoning afterwards squeeze the
lemon on top
[Music]
on the surface it's very crunchy you can
see the color in the middle it's a
different texture tender succulent
salmon flavor comes next i use the same
seasoning for all of them the pan-seared
is definitely more flavorful to texture
in your mouth dancing
and this one's i'm definitely the most
full whereas the other ones i could
probably have a big dessert afterwards
[Music]
[Music]
in terms of ease of cooking
definitely baking is the easiest i think
this one tastes the most salmony oven
baked salmon has the most silky and soft
texture there's minimal cleanup it's not
as oily or as heavy as the pan seared
one
[Music]
so
[Music]
i've never had parchment baked salmon
before when you cook the summer in a
parchment packet the steam is cooked
inside of the packet and when you unwrap
the parchment you just get this loft of
herbs and lemon and salmon flavor-wise i
can kind of taste lemon and thyme it
tasted super clean the texture is a
little bit
tougher than the
oven baked i would probably go with
either the parchment or the baked this
one might leave you a little unsatisfied
because it's kind of boring and bland so
if you're being healthy make it
flavorful too and go with one of these
guys they all taste like salmon
[Music]
oh yes
you